et nous avons été rejoint un plateau par
Régine ralege bonsoir bonsoir alors vous
reprenez le quiz du jeudi ce soir vous
allez nous challenger sur quoi Régine je
vais vous changez sur le cyclisme et
pourquoi le cyclisme parce que ce
dimanche 5 mars démarre la course Paris
- Nice aussi surnommé la Course au
Soleil et je suis aussi à préciser que
ce quiz a été pensé par l'une des
journalistes de rédaction Mélanie poquet
qui est fan de ce film voilà alors je
sais qu'autour de la table vous aimez
aussi faire du vélo donc ça ne devrait
pas être un souci pour vous de répondre
aux questions alors on va essayer de
répondre à vos questions en tout cas
juste un petit message pour les
personnes qui nous suivent sur les
réseaux sociaux n'hésitez pas également
à répondre aux questions en tout cas
tenter de répondre à ce quiz alors la
première question est la suivante depuis
quand la Course au Soleil Paris-Nice
s'élance-t-elle dans le département des
Yvelines vous avez trois options 2008
2010 ou 2012
moi je dirais 2010
[Musique]
bien un point pour Céline un point pour
Mathilde alors depuis 2010 la course
avait été lancée à Montfort-l'Amaury et
c'était le cours le cours néerlandais
Lars Boom qui avait remporté le prologue
et la course avait été remportée par
l'Espagnol Alberto Contador alors la
deuxième question en 2019 la Fédération
Française de Cyclisme décerne un prix au
département savez-vous lequel vous avez
également trois options terre
d'excellence cycliste département
d'excellence cyclistes ou territoire
d'excellence cycliste
alors moi je pense que j'ai la réponse
je vous laisse tirer la première oui moi
aussi je dirais la première terre
d'excellence département Territoire
tout le monde a juste alors je vais
mettre un point pour tout le monde
félicitations à vous
super super félicitations à vous donc le
label terre d'excellence cycliste il
valorise l'offre local de cyclisme en
matière d'espace de pratique et augmente
la tractivité et la visibilité du
territoire et reconnaît de des
potentiels organisateurs d'événements
sportifs alors la question suivante
combien de kilomètres de circulation
douce ont été réalisées par le
département des Yvelines vous avez
également trois options
850 km
1000 km ou 600 km
[Musique]
850 km je pense parce que j'aurais dit
600 mais je crois que c'est un petit peu
augmenté donc 850 les autres
participants
[Musique]
mais je veux dire si ça aussi
même la course encore donc très bonne
réponse c'est exactement 850 km qui ont
été comptabilisés en 2016 et c'est
depuis 2006 que les départements mènent
une politique pour justement favoriser
ces circulations donc on retrouve
beaucoup de circulation douce sur les
routes départementales les voies vertes
et forestières nous passons à
l'avant-dernière question je trouve que
vous êtes plutôt fort aujourd'hui on a
bien révisé voilà
alors la prochaine question donc il est
maire de sa commune depuis 2012 il est
aussi directeur de la communication de
la Fédération française de cyclotourisme
savez-vous de qui je parle
j'essaie de reconnaître la mairie qui
est caché derrière la petite animation
ça peut être un indice je pense que
c'est la mairie de Magny-les-Hameaux
très bien il y a maniyamu qui est le
maire Bertrand Houillon magnifique
nous passons à la dernière question
j'espère que certains d'entre vous
pourront se remettre en scène j'ai
préparé aux expressions alors où ce vélo
il se dérouleront les épreuves cyclistes
dans le département à l'occasion des
Jeux Olympiques alors attention c'est
plus difficile il y a des épreuves sur
piste des épreuves BMX sur route ou en
VTT
[Musique]
très bonne réponse
on a le vélo de route
et le BMX aussi
route ça sera en Vallée de Chevreuse où
je répète juste les réponses donc sur
piste le vélodrome national BMX Stadium
du vélo Drôme sur route en valise de
Chevreuse et VTT collines d'Élancourt
vous êtes vraiment excellente
aujourd'hui les filles ça après les
épreuves aux Jeux Olympiques on le dit
assez quand même assez souvent dans les
Yvelines donc ça va en tout cas pour
marketis il va falloir se remettre en
scène on fait du ballon
merci beaucoup Régine rallès pour ce
quiz on en apprend on va toujours un peu
plus sur les Yvelines grâce à vous merci